[Music]
I know that change can be scary but it
can also be exciting
[Applause]
let's start our new life
[Music]
since he
Roberts
does anyone in Andalusia ever just say
stuff not if we can help it
this world feels very different is it
sometimes easier to live in andalasia
well I wouldn't say easier we have
dragons and ogre rebellions last year
the entire kingdom was trapped in a
giant whale oh this is not a magic land
it is a land far far away from my
friends
I'm so late I'm a commuter now you're
riding this train over and over and over
and over and over and over and over and
then you die
as you can see Giselle everyone has
their place once you've found where you
fit Monroeville can be
every wish I wish for a fairy tale life
happily ever after it's not always that
easy
dresses low Jumping Jelly sticks we got
magic
town is turning into a fairy tale but
it's all gone terribly wrong I'm the
last stroke of midnight
nothing will be as it was before
an unevil cat I'm not an evil cat I'm
not an evil cat what is going on you
need to remember your place here Mr
mother please
Giselle is it under a curse we have to
stop this or everything animation will
die there's no one wishing your wish now
Giselle
come on time to be here you know there's
only room for one villain in this town
you're hilarious
delusional but hilarious
thank you
[Music]